a little bit a reject nation of Greg
Alba Don John Humphrey we're gonna watch
how Avengers endgame visual effects were
made by wired with the stones
danos snappy fingers topper wart ear
video requests from a man named Lance
door Canadian handsome nested who just
got engaged you gonna make her happy on
her honeymoon honey bone let's do this
Oh
my name is Jan hundred all and I was the
visual effects producer on Marvel's
endgame
my main tasks doesn't it work with our
directors John Anthony and our CEO had
to make sure that the vendors we are
bringing on board are the right vendors
Oh Joe and Anthony this is Johnny up the
ship
I have to look at these two movies as a
single project his family says movie
infinity ward's so in 2016 we knew that
very early on we were going to need to
test this before we even shot a frame of
footage to give some ease and peace of
mind to our filmmakers I guess this guy
could carry 2/3 of them we worked with
Josh's our production staff to bring him
in and work with Joe and Anthony we just
very early testing the mocap volume we
have the head cam setup he's got done
spacing that's what's gonna look like
did this this whole gauntlet yeah so
gauntlet after scanning capturing every
aspect of Josh's face in different range
of motions so not only was it a
technical discovery for us it was also a
character discovery for Josh John
Anthony when we found we kind of had to
imagine that as being this big I mean
you know kind of over-the-top character
but how Josh played it was beautiful his
performance was was menacing that subtle
terrifying but in in in little flinches
so we realized at that moment that we
really needed to have a company that
could the capture all that and pull his
performance through the prosthetic so
that when you were - on feeling so much
imagination
I wonder how these effects with age gave
them all this scanning data we gave them
all this footage and in the end a couple
months later they turned around a
version found them crazy like Josh
ideally in any situation when you have a
digital character you want to have two
actors we can replace it digitally but
we certainly can't manufacture that
performance so it's really important for
us to put the actors in a situation
where they are speaking to one another
face-to-face eye-to-eye when two eyeline
now it gets complicated by the fact that
that was 15 feet tall if josh is a
movement for example fighting with
anybody we put proxies on them we put
like displacement suits that's so that
if you have to touch him or interact
with them in any way the opposing actors
hands are in the correct position my
lines may be smashed a few things along
the way
so the whole goal was smart Hulk was too
smart hope that's what she calls what
was that gonna look like I put the
brains and the Brawn again and no
borrowing from the 2d designs that came
from Marvel we then had to sculpt two
smart Hulk into at 3d you always want to
have little anchor points in your
digital characters where you see your
actors features to some degree I'm happy
to kind of fell in love with him
actually when we started to see him come
to life and the more we found we
incorporated mark the more his
performance also stated for course could
I had the gun that the stones I really
tried to bring her back
ILM they had done so under something so
we knew that they already knew this
character they knew his skin how to deal
with this game technically they knew his
musculature inside balance so really
blending him with a more humanoid
proportion to character Wow
so we find that in visual effects the
more we stay out of the way of the
filmmakers and the actors the better
results we're gonna get the footage is
what we better here so I mean that is
genuinely not as fluid when that is
moving we really get the best of both
for us in a case like smart home you
want to make sure that mark is
interacting on set with all the other
characters the case of the event on pal
he needs to be there with Tony he needs
to be there but Natasha used to be in
that scene so we'll set up a motion
capture volume on set so he's surrounded
by cameras and using a mocap suit again
visual effects needs to really in all of
our technical gathering we need to take
a backseat to what's happening on
okay oh here we go
so in case of Captain America
what were you super soldier just like if
he had aged 106 years but his skin
looked like so we did some development
with that base that we should be once
they bought off and what that look was
gonna be we then started casting for
skin double looking around for an old
guy who shot in the same lighting
conditions right after Chris performs he
gives the same lines he tries to emulate
Chris's performance as much as possible
so that it doesn't take a whole lot of
hammering when we go on to Christmas
things in addition to the skin double
you also need to give him sort of an
older man's body older ends sort of
overall profile so as you've seen with
skinny Steve in Captain America one Bowl
is able to take significant size off of
Chris Evans pretty much in every
instance on Captain America Chris Evans
that's his body and he's a big dude we
need to get him down to an 80 pound
weakling to do so Lola will do an
overall work on his body and literally
they did the same sort of thing though
so it wasn't quite as beefy here we
shrunk his shoulders and
[Music]
now we've gotten engaged on mania we're
seeing Thor has lost everything
repeatedly so he has dealt with it by
eating a lot and drinking a lot and
playing video games of Kevin Dean
so to get this character we fought
really hard to make sure that we had a
practical solution to this because we've
seen it done before you can put a body
suit on somebody and it can work Marvel
contacted and contracted super
convincing large that's like a C's
prosthetic and hilarious
this better was [ __ ] with the Oscar it's
definitely a solid contender for visual
effects crazy cuz we just saw guardians
we had put him in costume which is
difficult but I think all of the
particles work had been done early on
him so it was just continuing his arc as
a character
the difference between human to that
character so that our camera guy knows
how to go from a digital thing this is
the fight of our lives
[Music]
very nice
and come on with that kind of being a
bubble around their head but as soon as
we started seeing it come up and I post
this footage we developed the Guardians
tech name just became the visor
[Music]
we shot this scene before infinity war
took two years scene but then we had
some defining moments where we would try
and make it recognizable as an area with
a collapse pay for spider-man
ah
[Music]
[Laughter]
pretty pretty cool moment pretty
energetic and I think people understood
ultimately we ended up having to go to
some of our characters off during
specific action beats and then it
happened quite a bit it gives the
filmmakers more flexibility and allows
them to steal parts from one
choreographed this I'm being a heading
everybody knows that's in full CG really
a filmmakers a lot of flexibility not
only their live action elements but with
the digital equations when you have a
beat that doesn't cut together smoothly
as you'd like
[Music]
[Music]
the face of the body we can convince to
face replacements
so why not get you here with falling 30
feet in there why not right here getting
you know punched pretty hard we're able
to do it so in that sequence it was a
combination Chris Evans shooting each
side and then the other active that is a
book on my son's team because they took
some pretty hard back upstairs so it was
a really aggressive style oh yeah
we're all pretty excited when Captain
Marvel came out
luckily we were standing on the
shoulders that development was happening
as we were posted so it was a little bit
of us chasing them down the line but in
the end I mean I think cool person every
time you see it in the movie when she's
in her full costume is digital again the
designs for those suits were not ready
in time for us photograph pretty so oh
really
rescuing Tony Stark you see her come
back when she's talking to net and the
Avengers compound with rocket and then
when she comes back it kind of saves the
day that's all the digital suit
the rat completely CGI right
[Music]
in our world for visual effects we do
want to try and get as much practical
they possibly can our supervisor made a
bet with the line producer that we would
have to replace the rat that appears
when Scott Lang is coming back from the
quantum realm to San Francisco and Dan
insisted that we could find a rat that
was trained and that could actually
behave on set my are lying for service
convinced they're gonna have to replace
it for those of you who are curious that
is not additional rat for all the things
that we do he's really there
where do you go it's good at his job
he's a trap there to get more work dr.
Doolittle is coming out yeah
oh yeah we didn't call me at this post
snap people disappearing that was months
at the Dalton and it was supposed to be
quiet it was supposed to be elegant you
know a little bit of pain mixed in but
the pain was really supposed to be felt
by the audience and their characters
disappearing so we wanted to give that
silence to the viewership it's okay
there's development we just kept running
soon after soon and landed on something
maybe you can wear more real suits now
oh don't I didn't think about Sony not
being able to have Marvel's VFX team
yeah let's get the PlayStation teams did
come on I think everybody could
visualize pretty clearly that that would
just be a little too weird you don't
really want to see that and it much more
powerful that happens off screen
the Tonys now that was challenging in
that we knew the emotional week that
that was going to carry we as our part
had to take a very vaccine to that
moment that performance technically
having the background there that was not
a problem but finding the right tone the
tendrils of the Infinity stone it's
eating away the suit is the student is
struggling and fighting to protect Tony
and you know in that moment that he's
not powerful enough to the stand what's
coming to be able to portray that in a
very quiet visual way and being the
background the but Robert was doing it
that long it was that's what it took
some time to get that right you want me
to find a dry eye on
I don't know it's gonna be really hard
for me in my career to top ten she's
making my house and a smart home I mean
those characters for visual effects
person you know pretty pretty cake so
I'm enormously proud of the work that we
did and the vendors who came to the
table with their a-game continually
challenging each other a fast studio
everybody we got performances
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
outside go see this what are you waiting
for
couldn't hear what he said over there
look cool everyone follow you what this
video made me realize I'm a jerk
yeah for crapping all over CGI yeah it's
like because I remember when we reviewed
infinity war and I was like no there are
times with an eye looks you know a
little fake and it really distracting me
when I watched this video Mike there was
so much CGI realized CGI is truly
mind-blowing dude yeah Alice and I did
never credit for those things that I
watched once a wolf of wallstreet CGI
breakdown and I was like what is this
guy but even like the beach in my like
that I like a completely constructed
Beach and then like there are so like so
many movies have CGI you never thought
was necessary the amount of different
effects in this movie alone and the
different gags they gotta pull off is
mind-blowing man like what they said
with the quantum realm suits what that
wasn't they were really wearing this
yeah I'm like I'm sure they did like
digital alterations especially when they
had to like transform out and the
helmets or whatever that shot when
they're all walking I'm like oh those
are cool new suits they pillows yeah
yeah yeah I had no idea that was not
real that totally blows my mind that
that isn't real I gotta give it to ya I
guess there's there's a big value in
like videos like this help to teach me
one of the things I love the most is
when she's talking about how they
consider what's going on in the movie to
approach the effects like we don't want
to get in the way the performance for
this part or we know that this moment
has to carry a certain amount of weight
and going back to what you said about
feeling bad about criticizing CG I do
think that that is like it really is up
to a good movie to make sure that it
presents it's CGI well because you know
like a movie like battleship I felt kind
of bad for all those animators who
probably put in a whole lot of time on
their work and who you know are getting
panned it's okay to criticize looks fake
knowledge and somehow infinity war if
you notice the effect I don't think
that's bad to do but I think who better
to balance it out by pointing out really
maybe do it so cuz I usually don't watch
these kind of videos on my own I was
thinking we're being asked to or
whatever and like that's just not a
quartic role of watching of course yeah
and something like this I usually don't
because I have this like weird the
preservation of magic I don't want to
pull the curtain back too much but then
when I watch them I'm so fascinated by
what's going on I just don't want to be
on the forefront of my mind but I've
seen and game so many times yeah what am
i learning about it by this point that's
I mean to watch a movie three times last
time being on the biggest screen I could
ever watch on with the clearest quality
I could ever watch it on and to really
be like what that fight between the two
caps that whole building was I was all
made up yeah I had no idea cuz I feel
you might be good to like maybe do a
little bit of research for films movies
it's easy to chalk chalk up like looks
fake looks real even the ones that look
a little bit faker you can tell or an
are not real it's like they clearly
still bust their asses for months on end
yeah try to make it as believable and
tangible as humanly possible something
like smart Hulk ish you called I don't
know I like that effect more than I like
the Thanos effect like the finest
effectors are like super impressive
absolutely and Josh Brolin really does
bring that performance to life and this
as well these visual effects artists but
smart Hulk there were so many times
where I'd say of course sometimes I
could see that it's you know not real
but there were times where I just looked
like practical effects to me I was
instantly able to get lost in that
performance of smart Hulk because of the
visual effects that provided for whereas
I remember fan o's took a little bit of
readjusting for me when I watched it
yeah and I mean the CGI over the years
has taken so many strides in like skin
textures and hair textures and stuff
like that and yeah a lot of lighting
yeah especially and all that yeah these
crazy physics engines that they have and
yet to render those effects in a way
that do move and breathe like a real
person might is super impressive
regardless of the times when it maybe
goes in and out but yeah like Hulk
especially in the way the interactions
go cuz that's the other hard thing and
they
brought that up about the Animus is 15
feet tall we got a make you know we have
to cheat you yeah you said that during
the reaction like how do they
choreograph all these things and it
really is mind-blowing yeah I think
you've got a small strip of dirt and
we're gonna create some magic camera
movement that's really gonna zoom boy
out yeah but dirt can't tell with these
things were like okay did they just have
like a few people and they just digital
effect the rest of the choreography like
do they make it up on the spot like Oh
be cool if we just did this moment right
here or while they're due and I'm sure
sometimes they do that but when you were
looking at the footage they filmed in
front of the green screen with all those
actors and the amount of things they did
set up every one of the heroes vs.
villains moments was preconceived before
they started going on the computer and
adding [ __ ] yeah nuts to me it's like
when I watch a movie like ready player
one I did enjoy the hell out of remember
Spielberg making some comment of yeah
they added things in there I didn't even
over in there yeah yeah and that's what
I thought some of that fight was like oh
they added that in later or like no
these camera movements are real camera
movements are not just in computer
camera movement so they're altering or
at least you know a lot of them I think
if you a a completely CG like nothing
on-screen is practical because that's
what always fascinates me too is what it
must be like for a cinematographer
because I'm sure you're jumping back and
forth between some scenes that are a
hybrid of practical and digital and then
some scenes that are completely digital
and yeah you know wasn't it Rango or
somebody that had like a legit
well-known cinematographer doing this
completely digital movie not that this
video you know wasn't completely
satisfying but I kind of wish we could
see some more about that - mm-hmm the
cinematography side of it yeah like how
as cinematographer gets involved with
things that are digital and yeah well I
noticed the most real looking fan of
shots I screenshot of one are the ones
words up close and I find that really
impressive how the closer you are to
these characters like smart Hulk like
fan oohs the more real they look which
is great which is like way better than
oh the closer you looked more fake it
looks you know we have to keep it for or
they'll also look for fake but I think
that's even more impressive they can
pull that side of things off because
whenever I thought finals look practical
it's on the close-ups well yeah and it
seems like they are pretty conscientious
with this movie about their approach to
the effects and you were talking about
Oscars but I think this is a great
example
a movie that does deserve and earn such
a you know nomination the very least
because you know there is a ton of CG
but there are a lot of different
approaches to it they're all put into
the movie and one feels like appropriate
places and with little things like that
it's like it's more important than when
we're up in Thanos his face and we're
feeling the emotion that he look as real
as possible and they put that effort
that time because CGI is also from what
I understand a time economy to you know
some things turn out the way they do
just because there wasn't enough time to
take them further I Sonic the Hedgehog
how they remake is gonna look a lot
better just so that more time better
yeah yeah you know just drop a patch
from the game right in I watched a
courtroom video recently where they
covered Captain America the First
Avenger so they talked a lot about what
she was talking about here
bobblehead Steve but having like doubles
there and then you have to do the same
shot two to three times like one woods
Chris Evans one would double and one
with nobody I find that very very
impressive and challenges that's so
time-consuming and challenging and the
fact that you have to make three
different shots all work together then
they said they had to hire an older
actor basically hired him to try to
exactly duplicate the movements I
remember when I saw Captain America and
the first time an endgame I honestly was
really late to the game to registering
that that was old man Captain America
yeah and I didn't register that I was
half hour after that yeah what I thought
that guy stole cap shield and then the
sequel is gonna go have to find cap and
see I didn't register especially that
that was Chris Evans there because those
effects looks so damn real I thought
there was just some old guy yeah then I
was hearing a voice I was like what is
that that is Chris Evans oh yeah and I
was wondering - cos old age is a hard
thing to do and it's fast it's yet to
take you know basically the BOA screen
is spliced yeah you know put a wig on
him yeah how they achieve that because I
know that's been a conundrum for effects
for a while is fascinating - a beautiful
marriage of skin textures and I think
the other thing you have to really give
credit to as well as of course the VFX
artist at the same time will really want
to make a lot of the VFX work is if you
don't have performers who can ultimately
here's their imagination
to the test of its ability will you
watch Thanos about to kill Tony's stark
and infinity war it's like you know
harrowing but then when you watch this
behind the scenes finishing tell us just
run a goofy suit and you got this like
have to use their imagination for this
really sad moment yeah 1 2 I've thought
of Christian Bale oddly enough because
also with for Josh Brolin and Mark
Ruffalo you've got a camera here
throughout your performance so you
always have something directly in your
feet'll division which has to be extra
distracting why do you think a Christian
man because uses distracting in the
middle the same you've got something
unnatural to the scene right in the
middle of your field of vision yeah
obviously gotta be a self-conscious
thing but to do like these powerful
performances and scenes that are that
rely so heavily where you can't really
use environment the physicality of the
conditions and and this and whatever the
production design has laid out for you
make us a big difference and what an
accurate can or can't do and like words
like these are gifts that he could use
or she can use to make it on that much
more real for them so for all these
actors to get so real and have to really
work past flip like yeah this isn't
really a spider-man suit at some black
thing with a bunch of dots this is a
really Hulk you know like the work past
all that is really really impressive on
an acting scale and that just goes to
enhance the visual effects to look more
real to yeah and the fact that you must
be watching this especially it hit me
that so many of these big glossy super
spectacular impressive movies have got
to be mostly made in just like a
warehouse with like some dirt a stone
and a lot of green yeah you know and and
that makes just the you imagine these
processes as being these they are huge
productions of people but yeah now I'm
just imagining like Chris Evans and
Robert Downey jr. showing up to a
warehouse yeah and it must be totally
different acting experience than I would
have imagined I guess through that lens
yeah alright guys well thanks for
watching do you hope that Avengers end
game wins the Oscar for Best Visual
Effects comment below will you care if
they do or don't that's
the question will keep it anyway you
guys subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell to get notified
whatever we got a YouTube video and you
can check us on patreon where we do
weekly Q&A is TV show reaction stream
along sync up but there's also options
for several shows where you can have
reaction highlights included the choice
is yours yes music video reactions
weekly Lance door thank you so much for
sending this over buddy I hope that is
soon you can officially decide where you
want to honeymoon with your future wife
to be I say you booked a concert for
California come out here visit us have a
little bachelor party just John Greg and
you oh yeah we get you to cheat on your
soon-to-be wife and her like please man
don't tell her and I'm like look I won't
have to tell her I have these photos I
took of you with the stripper where she
was doing things that are not legal well
you'll have to pledge $5,000 a month to
our patreon page unless you want her to
find out let's just say not tea not tie
knot tie knot eating a tie knot tie and
I know that's how II will not tie the
knot under our bribery influence we're
done